hello everyone hi what's up
uh i'm alana welcome to my channel today
i'm playing twin mirror this stream is
sponsored by dontnod who a lot of you
probably know i've covered their games
plenty before
uh but this one specifically is very
much up my alley in that it is
a detective psychological thriller which
is like roughly one thousand percent my
jam
my favorite game is deadly premonition
um
looks spooky atmospheric so we're gonna
play for a couple of hours
um there is a link in the description
below if you want to check the game out
uh i can throw that in here as well for
everyone i will just put
i will put the link in the chat
there you go uh
yeah it just came out oh and it is
on pc i'm playing on the epic game store
uh ps4 and xbox one
all right there you go
that's interesting alexander um
i'm gonna play with the controller just
because i feel like
you know we got the beautiful elite just
just a beautiful controller truly um but
also it seems like that
i feel like don't not games are often
controller
related why would i rate it out of ten a
great question cookies on a milky river
um all i've seen so far is the home
screen
so yep
uh will i be getting a cyberpunk review
code i will yes
uh i sure will okay let's go
let's do it tell me if i need to adjust
the audio at all
i do not know basement gaming i do not
know
the skies are finally clearing up after
a light rain failed
this is how every good detective game
starts by the way you're driving into a
town
down the premonition i guess also
alan wakes
[Music]
maybe i need to make myself smaller this
is too much alana
just put me down here get out of the way
i ain't too large for the video game
is my voice loud enough i feel like it
is i don't know my levels have been so
weird lately hello am i redlining i feel
like i'm redlining
a little bit it should be all right let
me know
resume
[Music]
oh bro i love cds when's it set
i haven't put a cd in a car in such a
long time
he's gonna smoke a cigarette
he didn't smoke a cigarette i feel lied
too
no cigarette just a lot of like sort of
headlines very upset
he's not francis york morgan but nobody
can be
if we're being honest
[Music]
rated out of 10 now that i played more
um
look it would be unethical for me to
read it uh
y'all know i don't review games i
haven't in like two years
um on this channel it was like two and a
half years ago
the song is nice i like the vibe
cool jacket um i like that they kept his
next double to realism you need that
good reflections on the call
i'm playing on pc he's using a nicotine
patch
okay it's loading
that's what happens why don't they ever
make spooky games with a female lead
i'm sure there are uh
the most recent amnesia rebirth female
lead
um there's one with a little girl
uh resident evil um
yeah no they do they do
i think what this kind of thing is
though like this kind of game where it's
like your broody detective this guy
doesn't actually look that booty but the
minute we hear him speak we'll find out
time to kill before the funeral might as
well spend it here he is exactly what
i'm thinking
it's the max payne type right which is
the same as alan wake
francis morgan does not fit into that
trip but it's it's the type of dude
who's very like
well i'm out here with my feelings
solving crimes you know somebody took my
wife
and i gotta find her i'm addicted to
pills johnny
i'm gonna go get drunk
it's a truck and i enjoy the trope and
max
payne is probably my favorite character
in the trope this place was always one
for decisions
somewhere for things to fall apart he's
doing it he's doing it
he's doing the thing um max payne is
always my favorite because he's so
extreme i love it a lot
that's my next vr roll thank you thank
you i work you got it yeah
i'm like ah you know i was on the force
i had to leave when they killed my son
welcome back to basswood i love it i've
like
have so much affection for the max payne
prototype man
this is uh very pretty i streamed um
tell me why not so long ago and
beautiful like
vistas of alaska could see the landscape
for days and i feel like this is
i came up here every chance i could even
prettier one of the all-time
great views here on my microphone that
makes a small town look big
let's move that i'm just gonna put that
over there
it's dealt with yeah i feel like the
don't know just keeps keep on stepping
it up very impressive stuff
ruined who wrote that which little
edgelord came up here and put ruined on
this sign sucks
bosswood is also a sucks to simply let
nature be nature outside of the
alpachian trail which it's hundred miles
with its hundreds of miles of hiking
trails
i also love that whoever wrote ruined
did it with really nice handwriting
it's a really nice ribbond they put a
full stop at the end and everything
amazing these
little graffiti artists in this town
nick would even want me at his funeral
given how i left things again the beauty
detective
it's him i remember spending entire
summers on the banks fishing with nick
i spent summers on the banks fishing
with nick
my hometown i felt more imposing in my
nightmares
question uh yes irish cake
okay i am on twitch and to the person
who said you can't donate on twitch
um no i do not have donations available
but thank you for asking that's very
kind of you
but no there is no way to give me money
on twitch um
[Music]
i did want to ask i feel like this is a
trope in a lot of games
and also and again not a thing i dislike
i'm actually quite fond of it
uh also in a lot of the music that i
listen to does anyone actually hate
their hometowns
i wonder if it's maybe a small town
american thing specifically
like i'm from a well it's a city it's
not that small like a kind of
smallish town in the grand scheme of
scheme of things
um i think it's great it's just too hot
anyone do you hate the town you're from
the town you're born in
it's truly is one big small town well i
was born in cairns
um yeah it's pretty mixed
yeah pretty mixed i think but i feel
like it's just such a like comment
without its mind what happened to the
best wood mines
oh my god full hazard noted
appreciate that appreciate that i like
the that's a very nice
uh ui
very nice it's beautiful
i get the feeling it still sees some use
given how bad the coverage is up here
i don't know you probably shouldn't be
using it in emergencies just because you
don't have signal that's
really nice ui look at that that's
snazzy um
you all got oh my god
this would be a good troll if anyone
just joins the stream now i hope someone
joins this exact second
wow you all got rats leopards
moose and dogs up here
that's crazy
oh look it's a bear i can't make any
jerky it has to just be a bad
sandwich in it for a whole week once dad
never let me forget it
it doesn't seem like that much of a
problem
it's just a sandwich this is okay i
don't have a problem with you doing that
is this anything like deadly proof
edition listen i've only been streaming
it for about 10 minutes
until that day so far the vibe is
similar which is um
what makes me interested in the game i
love this kind of thing
but i don't know you've seen as much as
i have
what's this oh it's his mind palace i
read about this
somebody took your clothes you've been
mugged
oh my gosh
why can't the real world be as clear and
peaceful as my own mind
my mind does not look like this you want
to know what the inside of my mind looks
like
it's just it's almost entirely titties
like 90 just boobs and occasionally a
puppy
does not look like a crystal staircase
even if it does the mine's closer
not even me if i don't see a single
titty
in this man's mind this is a lie
i don't buy it
it's not true it's just not how it's not
how people's brains work i know that
it's it's bio it's basic biology
of course with the exception of our
asexual friends
i uh well i relate to that i've been
meaning to ask you something
don't freak out would you be my little
girl's godfather
i wouldn't trust anyone else for this
okay can i stop taking his calls he even
called once the day before he died
i'll never know what he wanted to talk
to me about that haunts me
that exact concept i think about if i
miss a call
and then that's the last time that that
person tried to call me if they got in a
car accident or something i think about
that a lot
when i'm not thinking about titties or
puppies
this is anna she works relax uh does a
lot of the human interest pieces oh
they're journalists what can i say
i'm interested in humans and their
pieces
what do you like to write uh matt this
game is called twin mirror
that's about it it's a psychological
thriller from don't know this once it's
a stream thank you
sam be nice i had never met someone i'm
so interested
it's available now on pc ps4 and xbox
one
the story is important you know i think
that it's just
people around here have short tempers
and long memories
be careful sam
are you even listening to me
i wanted to say like but no
i wasn't listening deep as
someone who was a journalist for seven
years
um studied journalism higher education
uh bachelor of mass communication
majoring in journalism and entertainment
writing
the way that i see journalists talk to
each other
in media is nothing like my experience
that said games journalism
not quite the same
do you think this is going to be titties
i think this game's really pretty is he
iron man
look at this what is it someone skinny
dipping
[Music]
oh sam
what are you doing oh what happened to
her
i'm trying to be romantic
oh what wait oh no
oh this isn't what we wanted this isn't
what we wanted
i'm down on one knee a ring what else
would i be doing
oh buddy
oh heck ah you look like i just ran over
your grandma
oh yeah oh you hate to see it the
silence is really starting to scare me
now
anna please say something sam
put that away come on i don't want a
ring
i don't need a ring what does that mean
though
why oh oh you hate to see it
yeah you should know that we've
discussed it before was she against
marriage baby
which is fair i'm kind of sucky of him
if he ignored that
maybe that's what happened i suppose the
video game will tell us
in time
she did have cake though she was the one
brave enough to face that just want to
point that out
lost in my head again how much time did
i miss
bug i'm talking about bug stacks
um okay sure take a walk
on the prom promontory i've never heard
that one before
remember that night at the spyglass
return to the car you've wasted enough
time well i'm glad my inner monologue
doesn't do that to me frankly it does my
inner monologue is almost entirely
you've wasted too much time stop
sleeping you've wasted too much time
maybe it's for the best you're a dick
dude want me to let him down again
damn okay
nice shoes though i actually like his
outfit
well sorry walter but i don't think i'll
stick around i disagree i think we
should go
given up already just a quick
depressing down memory lane and then
you're gone
i know you think that the only thing
waiting for you down somebody is talking
to him
lots of hurt it's in his head it's like
it might be right uh dead labor
ammunition but it's been two years
it's time to face the world time to
adult
the good news though at least you don't
have to do it alone
[Music]
um
yeah i feel like we should go into the
town i'm in agreement that we should do
that
it looks pretty
twin mirror i wonder what wyatt's called
that and i wonder if that is in relation
to him having a man who talks to him
tyler dunn vibes yeah yeah
well i i didn't consent to you lying i
just wanted you to say you were almost
there
something well okay that's not what i
asked for
but i didn't want to go with the nick
won't even care anyway
since my wife and kids died all i want
to do is
work on the force
i started taking pain pills in my spare
time
it's all the kick keeps me
that's all it keeps me alive
one of the strangest things that
happened to me since lockdown started is
that i started snort laughing
um i did it out loud in a meeting today
something that i have never done before
in my life and i don't know why it
happened
is it that my face got lazier because
it's not around people anymore
i just keep snorting when i laugh and i
don't know where it came from
it's so weird
female geralt i don't think carol it
sounds like that
geralt is also not that moody he is
geralt is one of my favorite video game
characters ever
um because he's very moral
and has a sense of what is right while
also seeming to be brooding but he's
actually not that really
is the title supposed to be there
i feel like it's maybe not supposed to
be there
just a very long title sequence
really you actually came i really want
to let you know the name of the game
it's been a while
you've gotten taller you want to make
sure you're away
52-foot geralt statue are you serious
jacob
we're talking right now
it's cold
i've always wondered if
you thought the kid was gonna drive the
car and i was very worried i've always
wondered if denim actually makes people
warm
i've never worn denim that's not fair
you left
i think it's a dry it's a lie brother uh
oh uh uh
oh i feel like i should get rid of the
title sequence we should restart the
game
okay i do that
and then do that and just re-jump into
that
unless it was supposed to be that but
that seems unlikely
why whoa we moved to a different part of
the screen but oh my gosh
and then i gotta move the chat over
because now the chat's in the wrong
place there we go
okay i'm gonna give you guys a link just
while we're here
there you go if you want to check the
game out you grab that link enter
press enter to enter i see what you did
there
okay
what am i drinking literally always a
latte but i also have a thermos full of
tea
is anybody i love it uh and some water
love a beverage love a beverage
okay there we go we did it
i'm just trying to tell you the name of
the game what kind of tea
it is pg tips with a tiny bit of milk
i missed the title all right i'm sorry
so this is not an alpha but i do have a
pre-release build of the game the game
is out now but
my build does still say the old
builds name so um it is possible that
uh i've just not updated um and that i
do have a more beta version that see i
didn't see that that's my kid
well i didn't know that because i was
looking at the title screen okay
we're still gonna not gonna let joan
drive okay we're not
you actually came we're not gonna let
joan drive it's been a while
you've got please don't let john drive
apparently that's my kid can we talk
it's called twin mirror i'm really sorry
that i took it away i could add it back
to png and put it on the stream if you
really miss it that much
hmm
no driving
so you left i guess he hasn't seen his
kid in a while joan that's not fair
you left
sorry seems a good call look joan
i messed up you said you wouldn't leave
you said you said i don't remember
exactly but you pinky swore
i didn't mean to lie i just screwed up
after anna broke up with me i'm i'm
sorry i wish words meant anything
i wish this didn't make it harder for
you to trust me now you could have at
least
called something pretty rough man
eventually after
oh so that's not after my dad i saw her
real dad
i don't know what to say to that i see
okay
the pieces i am picking them up i wasn't
in a state where i could reach out to
anyone
because i was doing pills after the
force
it's all i could do still not if nick
hadn't died i never would have come back
thanks for being honest you're always at
least honest
i respect it you could have two dads
it's true
uh um this is not a david cage game it's
a don't not game
i wanted to talk to you about similarly
narratively focused i would say
it doesn't make sense he wouldn't have
just crashed
he drove i mean i have two dads
yes character is sam nick died oh game
volume up i can do that
but it'll have no volume for a second
yeah let's see how that sounds she's
just oh he's goddaughter i see that's
the one that he mentioned when he was on
the hill
a pi or a cop you're the closest thing i
can talk to
will you just look into it muley please
she wants her father's death to mean
something
but where is that is that lawrence
what if it leads to the truth that could
change everything
an hour ago you wanted to run away we
all just have a lauren
sun tag in the back of our head says
what's death a few questions
which i would buy just tonight to
reassure her
and myself this is awake
if you poke around people may end up
poking back
okay whatever you do at least leave the
kid out of it
it would be cruel to lead her on friends
don't lie to each other
even if it means disappointing her again
i like him it's your call i'm a fan of
brain lawrence uh
i'm gonna help the kid
okay how could you not when she's
staring at you that intensely for that
long
gum shoot up that's what i wanted
gabriel if it was his therapist
you make some good points it doesn't fit
i hate when things don't fit
yeah me too i might just be
i don't know crazy or something but you
want to know for sure i just keep
thanks emily i would die for her i am i
should go in before my mom misses me
you better get in there too right nick
is dead yes okay
yes piecing things together
i do you got dunked on by a
six-year-old six maybe ten i'm really
bad at guessing the ages of kids she
could be 14.
i'm always way off
six i genuinely have no idea
like but still you got dunked on bro
i don't know i don't know
12.
i saw a two-year-old once and i was like
i think they're probably about five
and my family laughed at me i just don't
know how to guess the ages of children
i really don't
i don't know why i just i think i don't
see children enough
we just have no idea
well she went into the ball because it's
awake they've
rented it out for her dad's funeral
you're right there are the pills
i took pills since anna left me nothing
got me through life anymore except for
the pills and
so alone nobody
gets me writes itself it writes itself i
should write video games for a little
bit talk to walter
i'll have to i will not walk faster and
the suggestion offends me
yes the cat food is under the sink yes
yes it is texting me oh foam of us
oh samuel is here i'll call you back
i never asked for this samuel higgs as i
live and breathe
has it really been over two years
regardless i'm so glad you finally made
it
thank you it's pleasure to be here what
kept you the drugs
on memory lane oh i missed the funeral
but i made it to nick's wake
you have to bring it in for a hug it's a
basswood back in town requirement
it's so good to see you even if i wish
yeah
in times like these we need the
comforting touch of others well now he's
made it weird we could have just hugged
he didn't need to give me
his face actually looks really good
though again i think that that's that's
a
step up even from tell me why um
i suppose i've played though have you
spoken to anna lately
no this is all pc um no reason
if you get the chance we should catch up
we should really catch up
is anna married she was gonna be married
i knew it
she married some jerk as soon as i left
town i was never the same again
what what did he have gone for a cushy
job and a nice car
i didn't think she cared about that
stuff i'm doing so well at getting into
this character is all i'm saying
things change i guess when you leave
town
people change
hey okay don't make fun of my
impressions of sounding like i'm having
difficulty breathing
i have asthma okay it's not fair
let's be on game pass like tell me why
i'm not sure it is on xbox one though
coal miners haven i would totally go to
a
very empty bar named well okay it's a
wake that was rude alana
you're not gonna make fun of the
atmosphere
a man's died big investigative reporter
that's what happens whenever i go home
back to australia at the airport they're
like
alana pierce big shot
x games journalist every time and you
are leaving town right after this right
that's not a fight just really embracing
those hick stereotypes huh
get you good old boys another round
mighty kind of you declan
you're not worth the higgs oh we touched
the titty he did it he touched he
touched him making friends already i see
that no it's been a while i don't have
any friends careful
i'd rather not be worried sound like
batman and you always seem to angry up
everyone's blood
[Music]
i'm only here to pay my respects to nick
nothing more nothing less
yeah shame though i'm genuinely
impressed by their faces again huge step
up from uh previous it's just a
different style i suppose but it looks
looks good
his facial hair looks great i think it's
time i go put up a photo at the memorial
board
that's what people do right i guess
that's
one of the conventions of the funeral
i don't know all i know anymore is
drugs like a drinking gin
oh i'm a [ __ ] idiot okay let's where
am i putting this thing oh sammy oh it's
been ages
tara oh me i've had this stomach thing
lately always churning
i love her and this thing with nick his
car went up like a
sunday ham oh well that's alive you know
that's okay that's [ __ ] up
you've lost me a bit here tara i was
about to stay
the infamous sir you just talk about a
dead man like that
[ __ ] that you wrote on the mind you
should promote a lot of league work on
that
um took a lot of research it took
reading thousands of public records but
a pattern emerged of willful negligence
you are a bulgar dangerous man to anyone
using power to exploit others
that's nice of you to say that is nice
don't hesitate to drop by the pharmacy
sometime
oh and so for now
you're not here oh right
don't be a stranger sam i still think
she's very cute
so i'll give her that all right
kathy what are you about you're gonna
talk to me there you go
there was no love lost between kathy and
nick since they're divorced
but anyone can see she's taking his
death hard well
you know you probably would jay talk to
her cathy
sam you actually came
it's been too long kathy i think that i
should play into the stereotype
actually i should make him more broody
in my dialogue choices i'm always nice
i'm going to make him more broody after
the breakup and
jones never had a lot of friends jones
yeah my god daughter
um maybe don't break her heart this time
when you leave town
all right
i feel like john thinks nick was
murdered your daughter thinks
nick's crash doesn't make sense this is
your small breeze she's an optional girl
who lost her father she's confused right
now
don't you go encouraging her or worse
putting those thoughts in her head i
frankly thought you knew
you're right exactly tourist do you
think nice doesn't match the batman
voice
i think you she does have intense
eyebrows so do i though i've got an
intense brow
how's it just very angular i think why
not too though i started drawing them
higher on the outsides and i like it
not that i draw them on that i mean
they're tattooed but
that will sound strange to anyone who
doesn't understand makeup you'll think
it's a lot more extreme than it is
um oh mind palace well i'm gonna pin
first
sorry we lost touch sorry i lost touch
rest up big guy that's pretty sweet of
you
this photo always looked weird nick
could never keep a straight face
that's rude the man died
i don't even think that he looks that
weird there
what that why you gotta arrest him like
that
nick and anna happier times she
she was it sucks at my best friend we
drove straight to the sea after work on
a friday
hell of a weekend is this all photos of
is that supposed to be you
that's a foot it is who pinned that
there
i guess it's a good photo of him
oh walter those two were a great team
i think i love him okay shall we mind
palace i'm ready i think it's this one
no i feel like i've lost it
it's too bad it's gone samuel uh
slamming nick died in
an explosion in a car yeah that bet
you'd never come back to basswood
not after that you went careening out it
was probably like a bad out of hell the
ins and outs that article broke bad
that's not why i left that wasn't the
reason i left town
oh you think it was that he burned a
laugh you know exactly
you left because the town hated your
guts what are you even doing here dennis
you and nick become friends or something
nope he thought i was a drunk which i
am and i thought he was a hack which he
was
this coming from the i.t guy didn't know
resetting passwords could give you a
journalism degree
okay it can but it does give me less
patience for people who sling mud my way
you just threaten you just relax i'm
just playing
all right cheekbones at least tell me
how you've been
yes yes yeah like you'd care
not too much i don't want to be rude to
people i want to be like that
i just want to be self-deprecating
that's my man that unlike us people
actually liked
speaking a witch
oh it's my ex she done left me
[Music]
i love looking at the way that they
animate strings
it's really cool and uh spotty
also very good
[Music]
[Music]
you're not technically wrong really does
have a nice guitar
i would have bought that guitar they
came out with them it's so
pretty and the guitar like really got me
[Music]
emotionally
[Music]
all right look like you don't kill her i
wish
that you were
it's tea time my tea is ready guys my
tea is ready oh
oh heck oh heck oh everybody's sad
wow this tea is colder than it should be
[Music]
still warm enough though
the girl who broke my heart well
i guess i knew i'd see her again
eventually
guess it's time to face reality
i just feel like i'm really developing a
character here okay i think that
um there's a little bit of work left to
do but
it's really common together
anna sam
he'd hug her back yeah
i've missed you have you why'd it take
so long why would anyone need some
[ __ ] like me
okay what what did you ask me um it
hurts to come back
i won't lie it really hurt coming back
i stopped by lookout point on the way
here sam
why'd you do that to yourself i desire
to open old wounds
the old-timers gave me hell when i came
in too it was like two people
around here have short tempers one
really in long memory everyone else is
fine
but most of them mean well the old
timers
anyways maybe any year or two
five if the lord has a sense of humor
it was gonna run dry or have an even
bigger disaster
it wasn't your fault
it didn't help i wanted to help i was
trying to make things better
you always do try at least
when my father lost his legs uh no thank
jesus i am playing this on pc
regulations
right now currently playing on pc but it
is also on xbox whenever people talk
about you
there's a link in the description check
it out you don't put it in the chat
thank you matt
yeah well i appreciate it
boom
do i have any advice for writing i also
studied screenwriting diego
um my biggest piece of advice is to just
do it a lot
genuinely and read a lot it wasn't just
him
nick thought your piece was great i will
stream cyberpunk on embargo yes
he always which is actually going to be
3 a.m
i will be streaming awake streaming 3am
you know nick and i had moved in
together
started to get serious but i think it's
only now i realize
how much i cared for him oh that's
interesting
but you and nick started going out when
did this happen
a few months ago he he never told you i
don't have any friends he asked me to
let him be the one to say something
you two had been so close but didn't you
two date he probably tried
what do you mean you two had been so
close didn't you didn't he propose to
you
no i think the ex is the one who says
the thing are you joking
anything broken just stays well maybe
not
depends how far apart this maybe the
friend is the one
the funeral the weight just don't do it
really good
probably not date your friend's ex i
would actually tell them first
heavy makes my heart hurt a fancy
filmmaker i use a logitech breeze he's
been laid on top of me and i'm still
carrying him
look i feel like the character i've
created here of who sam is would say i'm
sorry nick's gone but i want to ask if
he was murdered
nick's death do you know if he had any
enemies working on anything dangerous
now this is a can
yeah i know that do you
this isn't the time to be digging i do
have my pc build listed you always do
this um
you always on my apartment tour video
you can find out all my pc specs
on youtube you're still you but i will
be updating it very soon and i'm very
excited about you
sam i just i have my shuttle back you
never change
my shot is on backwards look i'm gonna
go home
[Laughter]
oh wow amazing incredible i don't even
know what shot this is what what lego is
this
samuel come have a round of applause i
need a drink or two
i have no idea three and then i'll go
okay um
i don't what would i do what would he do
i feel like he would follow the girl
is what he would do he would leave
because she left oh but i do really like
tara
so it's so tragic what happened to nick
the details are
you're so [ __ ] up tonki didn't die on
impact instead
he roasted what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you death
woman damage the bones but you know not
a pretty sight oh my god
unless you're into that kind of thing of
course i didn't mean to be rude sam
i didn't even say anything i just walked
in her general direction
you seen this what the heck
um okay it's all right or you were no so
here's the thing
about the the sam that i am creating
right
he would not be rude to he's not going
to be like you were rude because he's
too self-deprecating to think that way
okay he has no self-respect
so he is only ever going to be like it's
fine everybody's rude to me
because i'm a piece of [ __ ] and i
deserve it so
it's all right it's all right tara i
don't like the sight of dead burned
people
oh my god oh my god i wouldn't want to
be rude on a day like this
sam is a sad man correct correct now
that nick is gone everyone in town now
that i can feel it
i could feel it that's not my job you
destroyed
you're not the cause of my problems i
mean that's what you did for pretty much
all the basswood but
not to me so i don't hate you
thanks for the confidence booster tara
i'll see you around
amazing she's um can i keep talking to
her
nick was the good sort sometimes the
good sort die like the bad sort
it's not fair i think you're [ __ ] up
but i love you
sometimes the good sort guy like it's
not fair you're the most interesting
woman i've ever met in my life taro
and i never want to leave
you're you are like watching someone
get roasted in a car you know it's
awful and confronting and shocking and
why why would anyone
want to see that but you can't stop
looking
that's tara that's tara okay i'm gonna
leave
but i but i miss you already oh she
looked back at me
oh my gosh it's fine we'll be back we'll
be back
wait can i not leave yet oh heck i
missed whatever the objective was
because i was too busy paying attention
to my own shirt
um don't care much for dennis
no can't fit through there apparently
i wouldn't mind talking to the sheriff
about mr heads good to see you my
condolences if he really
died by accident i've seen a lot of
friends
it is very difficult to face it's a fake
a cod save the day people try i don't
want it but
the minute there's fire involved you can
tell what the sources
don't worry i won't stay in town long
enough for that
one quick thing nick's death are you
sure
it was an accident are we sure what are
you trying to say
i really like to do something i don't
know you're a bird dog at heart and a
bird dog
hunts but listen nick's death was an
accident don't go riling people up
don't you think you've done that enough
to the nice folks around here
i guess so thank you enjoy your evening
i may as well be
ryan i have i have watched like 300
episodes of forensic files this year
okay
here's the thing like i said
uh excuse me you can always tell
the source of a fire it is so difficult
to fake
how a fire starts almost impossible
you'd think a kid at a bar would stand
out more
why did you have to roast her like that
also this is creepy can we talk about
what you're doing here
can we can we talk about this
it's it's just it's quite intense my
dude
um we're going to talk to ethan
i didn't know you read dickens ethan
he's owned this bar for almost a decade
and still can't afford another employee
you just quoted him a couple of times
and i thought it sounded good
oh check that bill so nick wasn't drunk
and me i was drunk as a skunk ah samuel
samuel samuel i like walter i hope he's
innocent i'll be very upset if he's not
let me get your next round maybe ethan
has a suggestion
for a worthy spirit well spirits
oh no no friends drink beer yes i
suppose that's fitting
to dear nicholas
i can't wait until yeah you know
come in a lot lately the situation set
right there it's over and i can just
have videos with friends
with friends i guess that'd be real nice
indiana well by himself with his laptop
as his date
you never drank a loan you two were
close though right
tell me about the man outside the bar he
had a terrible memory
couldn't remember names dates passwords
kept his notes was he
a journalist i have like an incredible
memory for quotes
and that's the thing that came through
studying journalism being a journalist
is like i know it sucks for people who
date me i can be like no no
you said this on this exact date like
100 um i remember that stuff perfectly
so weird
um what would i say
we hadn't talked in two years i don't
know
i hadn't spoken to him in almost two
years i cut this whole town out of my
life and now it's like i'm a stranger
this place is in you he'd say something
it's like an old glove
because any excuse he can the friend
that insults himself
my briggs personality type michael i am
intj
few hearts like his with virtue warmed
few hearts with phenomena correctly
pretty sure yeah intj there's another
whatever the the least common one is
um there is none he made the best
and it's also very specifically about
being a person who does a lot of charity
work because literally if you look it up
no
robert let me google it make sure i'm
right about intj
intj
i might be wrong about it
um it's the architect
it might be infj that i'm thinking of i
n
fj i can literally look up least common
personality type
infj there you go that's the one infj
is my maya brick personality type the
advocate
they list it as which i feel like is
very fitting because this is 100 who i
am this person
um
[Music]
i mean it is you know you just read it
really if you want to look up what infj
means but it says
advocates generally strive to do what's
right and they want to
help create a world where others do the
right thing as well people with this
personality type may feel
cold to use their strengths including
creativity imagination sensitivity to
uplift others and spread compassion
uh advocates may see helping others as
their purpose in life
they are troubled by injustice and they
typically care about more about altruism
than personal gain
as a result advocates tend to step in
when they see someone facing unfairness
or hardship many people with this
personality type also aspire to fix
society's deeper problems in the hope
that
unfairness and hardship can come things
of the past i feel like that is 100 who
i am as a human
one thousand percent career paths i
wonder what it lists career path that
aligns with their values
rather than one that offers status and
material gain
yeah fair yeah
yeah basically uh infj is
um advocate someone who
is introverted intuitive feeling and
judging
um but a lot of it is about helping
people and i think that is pretty much
what drives me as a human
like 100.
that's i feel like that's probably
pretty obvious in a lot of the stuff
that i do
there's definite overwhelming need
to help people anytime i see something
bad happen
um which can get a little bit exhausting
but mostly
feel like i do the right thing uh anyway
back to the video game
there are definitely plenty of things
wrong with my personality for the record
not trying to suggest that uh i don't
have my problems but
um i would agree that helping people is
my number one drive in life
for sure um anyway hi we're playing uh
a twin mirror uh this is a game from not
entertainment
link in the description if you want to
check it out i will throw it here also
boom nope that's infj
let me find the link
am i saying i want to be a superhero not
quite the same
not quite the same as wanting to be a
superhero because
i don't care too much
about i'm very anti-violence
but i feel like being a superhero in a
lot of ways is just um
reactive i try to be proactive
that's where you can actually get the
game if you want to do your personality
type test look i don't believe
any of these are like ever going to be
100 correct like when i read over the
infj description this is on
16personalities.com
i'm like yeah this 100 aligns with who i
am um
advocates may be reserved but they
communicate in a way that is warm and
sensitive i 100
believe that's true uh
the cost of success they may focus so
intently on their ideals if they don't
take care of themselves one thousand
percent
i've like fallen apart this year because
i've been like i need to do
more work to help people and it's not
i'm never doing enough
and that's definitely a thing um
advocates may feel they aren't allowed
to rest until they've achieved their
unique vision of success
one thousand percent a lot of ps2 a t
but this mindset can lead to stress and
burnout yup
i mostly screw my relationships up is
more of a problem with that
i don't give the people in my life
enough attention
um find themselves feeling especially
stressed in the face of conflict
see that's not true i'm fine with
conflict i think i
like brush it off like it's nothing
really
personal mission they feel compelled to
find a mission for their lives
when they encounter whatever this is not
interesting to anyone
someone brought it up and now here i am
but yes
here's the video you check out video
game it is out okay let's go
just something i keep on hand for toast
max confidant with tara
but i would never cheat on my girl like
that whose name i'm now forgetting hot
nurse what's her name
completely blanking on her name um okay
people sure liked him everyone liked him
i think even dennis liked him somewhat
yeah the hot guy
a lot of friends from personal naked
sent flowers
that's what i'm referring to there's a
family taking it
joan and kevin don't know what her name
is it's definitely not catholic he has a
lot to deal with
now more than ever but who can prepare
for losing a parent
not a soul not a single soul
i just i would just love to have a beer
out of a glass i would just love it i
would really
sit down cathy what's your underage
child doing drinking
no control over her [ __ ] yeah you little
six-year-old
doing anything
leave me alone ah you guys are all so
so stupid you do not talk to people that
way
that got out of hand i'm
i'm sorry everyone she's just so
that did that did escalate very fast
there though that did get
oh my god now all i can feel is this
this tag
that was quite heavy-handed um st man
four a lot of people have been talking
about
this looking like a david cage game
um it is obviously not a quantity game
i've been to their studio
saw a lot about how they make games this
is don't nod similarly
a bunch of french dudes actually so not
that different oddly
um and they definitely do both have like
similar narrative vibes like i
understand the comparisons to heavy rain
of course because this is a
broody detective situation like heavy
green but still
fairly different i don't think that
don't nod and and
quantico the same dna entirely um
they still are very unique and this
feels very different to everything that
that dandon has made
for sure in my opinion um much more on
board with this than
i have been with some of their other
titles because i love a detective story
uh such a sucker for it and i hope this
gets spooky because i love that too but
um
what would i what would i say what would
i say
kathy was hosh declan was hosh declan
was harsh
kathy was fine declan sure came at her
with both barrels
joan's tough though
she'll be okay yeah i agree with that
jared twin peak survives with life is
strange
oh i got spooked but i sped up
hello wannabe gamer what's up
i love a drinking montage seriously and
then
i did all i could do i got drunk
what else is there to live for anymore
my
ex-girlfriend what ended up with night
lawrence
i'd say that went well ish
you got to chat with everyone you've
been avoiding yeah
even if joan got inside your head with
her whole dad
mystery death thing just i mean a car
just lighting on fire is
pretty weird i did see that vast driving
debates that's your idea
you're the one in the driver's seat sam
i can't make you do anything
deep down you've been looking for a
reason to come back
they should have cost lauren sontag to
play this role it's gonna be one of
those long nights inside your head huh
i didn't ask you to be here hey i didn't
i didn't ask for you to be here
i haven't had to act drunk i think i
have this and it's very fun i think i
did once
you can't see it now but the guilt would
have eaten you alive
you're back out in the world feeling
emotions
fitting in that's progress [ __ ] the
world mm-hmm
that's my boy [ __ ] the world and more
talking
and no one says what they mean go away
lords can only force characters examples
just try and make sure you don't do
anything stupid
that jolly technology is crazy it's so
cool
so cool
i'm not sure if he's the devil's
advocate he might be like his therapist
he could be
someone else in his brain for some
reason um
obviously my favorite video game ever
deadly premonition plays with the
concept of another character talking to
me
that nobody else can necessarily see
i think because of that i've always been
a fan of it i like it so obviously tyler
didn't ask too but that's a little bit
different
no stay out we have 10 minutes before we
charge you for another day
that doesn't happen by the way okay i'm
gonna monsters have a check out at night
i
have been late to check out of a hotel
it happened last night many a time
oh my god one time i had an asthma
attack plus
drinking they don't notice for an hour
my best idea and then
you can be like hey i black out or what
was unwell
uh sorry and they're like it's cool
she's probably going to be gone before
fall
you're like alright sick it's like
cleared up
never as aggressive as people think
new day new pain he's exactly who i
thought he was
that's what i am talking about
this looks like both the hotel room and
the view
the last time i was in salt lake city
like almost
exact on point clearest code do i have a
favorite book or simply one i'd
recommend
i would recommend and this is a short
story not a book you read it in five
minutes
but i always recommend it because it
sticks with me so well uh
look up the actual name i think it's
those who walk away from omalas but i
want to check
i got it perfectly right let me just
give you the link you can read it right
now four pages
go read this book it's my uh
definitely my favorite short story i
love it
god but yes i read a lot of books i feel
like a small
jackhammer in my left temple
the stench of cigarette smoking beer is
all over me
what was i supposed to do
amira do you think i'll find a twin in
it i was at least hoping i'd look better
than i feel
he has no body hair you think this
dude's out here getting waxed i feel
like that would be an interesting
character boy
i already feel more human
now where did i put my shirt you're not
gonna
wipe your face off first oh thank you
elijah
i'm also excited for cyberpunk 2077.
oh
[Music]
you do not love to see it
that's not good that's
where did i get this
it's your own shot what did i do
oh you think you killed somebody
i didn't i wasn't that concerned about
it i looked at it was like you got in a
fight
somebody beats [ __ ] but i guess he
doesn't have any blood on his face which
would imply that somebody else
did that
teddy palace back again
it's red
[Music]
oh oh oh we're already at a chase
sequence i hope this game's inspired by
daily premonition
i want to turn around i can't control
the camera bomber devastating
absolutely devastating
okay hey big boy more careful oh i'm
supposed to avoid
those focus well you didn't tell me that
am i supposed to go through that one
i don't just don't feel like you can be
i'm unclear on the mechanics
is my problem am i supposed to go
through the green ones i think that
maybe i'm supposed to go through the
green ones should i try it
if i try to go through that nope
oh gosh oh hello hello find a way to
calm down
he's very close
i guess that could be because i smacked
into the pole
let's try it again
just not supposed to go through any of
them sam
focus you have to find the right door
you need to steady yourself oh i do need
to find the right door
oh uh well
i feel like they're all
pretty much the same oh the one that
says steady itself that checks out
okay that seems
that seems right i wonder if you could
ever die that
oh no oh big boy
we why did we jump to the conclusion
that he killed someone
i just don't feel like
like that necessarily happens whenever
you see blood
you know
take control take a trip take a trump
like i would think that i had a
nosebleed would be number one
um
and then i would think that somebody
punched me would be number two
but i guess if he didn't find any
blood on him that's you know
um and then i would think i helped
somebody if i'm being completely honest
i'd be like clearly somebody was
bleeding and i i assisted them
i stopped to help them while they were
bleeding on the street
it would be a lot a long list before i
would be like
[ __ ] i've killed someone oh are these
the twin mirrors
really good thank you lauren almost
there thank you i appreciate that
shirt covered in blood can be a
nosebleed i used to have pretty brutal
nosebleeds okay
like and you can just get everywhere
focus choose act
deliberately
okay don't know about that one don't
know about that one
just go i feel like it's gonna be the
one i'm gonna let you decide chat which
mirror
left middle or right i feel like it's
probably left
but where do you think i should go which
is the correct mirror
so far we have right left and middle
you think it's i think it's the most
left
i think what i think it's mostly with i
think this is correct
because it said answers yes answers good
or bad i need answers
genius genius
still not sure why you think you've
murdered someone
i know what you're thinking stop
thinking that
pills paul you're lucky enough you
didn't wake up dead
i need to know what happened last night
last place i remember is the bar so i'll
start there
the squeaky nail gets hammered down but
what if i don't play
drink my drag first oh goodbye justin
thank you for joining me
also hi everyone who welcomed
hi everyone who welcomed hi everyone and
welcome
this is what i think i was trying to say
i'm playing twin mirror
it is out right now on
that's the ones who walk to omales so
keep like forgetting what i have in my
notes stuck um
there we go here we go here we go here
we go you want to check it out if you
want to check it out there you go there
you go there you go
yeah it's on uh pc ps4 xbox one right
now
it's made by dart knot not by quantic
uh what would he say i know how to blend
in
nobody sees me especially not whatever
my ex-girlfriend's name was was
alex i think it was alex alex doesn't
see me at all
i can poke around without making waves
mostly
it used to be my channel it's not a
generation of facts
not quite so good at blending in
i can't just run from whatever this is
so either help me or get out of my head
what if it was just a nosebleed i just
live here
just a nosebleed could have been
somebody else had a nosebleed
have you ever had a bloody mouth because
the way that blood
stains um saliva is very intense it can
look like a lot more blood than it is
okay i don't know why you've decided
you committed a murder because what if
you didn't
that's all i'm saying what if you didn't
[Music]
oh he added a hoodie
hmm
laura's living
do you really think breaking and
entering is a good idea
used ethan's hidden spare key no brakes
thank you the
i don't know what if it was just a late
night bugger ketchup incident
we've all had those when drunk i picked
them what if it's just tomato soup
okay you big dummy all right buddy what
do you you don't know what you're doing
let's do this and let's do this okay
cool is the person i murdered in here
no i know it tastes all too well
all i do is drink frost it
your voice is just getting lazier as i
go on ethan's accounts
doubt ethan's account somehow led to the
blood on my shirt
well i don't know i i've fought a couple
of [ __ ] over accounting before
so you can never rule it out it's
the number one reason i get into a
ruckus
is uh counts
it's heated stuff
whoa what happened here last night
first look around gotcha
figure out what happened it looks mostly
fine but i understand
things have been flipped and nobody did
anything about it i ended up drinking
alone
so who brought that second glass
interesting
oh you wanna steal some cash
i'm up
oh ethan tried to clean up huh okay is
that blood
oh my mom's calling me oh you hate to
see it i will have to call her back in
roughly 45 minutes
okay these were sent scattering
someone thrown into them i do not know
i do not know a good question
what is that
it's pepper that's fine ripped
did this happen yesterday or was it
always like that i'm talking about my
own abs
because i i don't eat because i'm
depressed it really writes itself
ah well that's [ __ ] up
did i do this that's not good
sorry nick did i have to get a license
with pac-man it is a really good
question
i don't know can we play it hell yeah
[ __ ] nick michael michael michael
michael
mcmahon bad news everyone i'm pretty bad
at pac-man
uh this is gonna be the rest of the
stream thank you all for joining me
today
the stream in which i play pac-man
really appreciate your support during
this difficult time
all right let's do this oh
oh i missed up i went up but it didn't i
should have played it on d-pad
that was that sucked that was not fair
because i actually wasn't [ __ ] up
there
d-pad d-pad d-pad doesn't work
devastating
that one wasn't even my fault up up up
up up
none of this is my fault this is absurd
absurd i tell you i'm trying to do the
right thing and it won't let me do it
you know it's just okay you know you
know
i'm gonna go down
and then do this and do this and then
you eat them all
don't really want to do this right now
fine you know it's fine
should have gone for more there it
wasn't the play i wanted
you know it wasn't the play i wanted
neither was that
i never even went
[Laughter]
that time i ran out right there
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous garbage
video game
it'll never take off never
that wasn't fair it wasn't fair
um what is this what has that symbol in
the top right always been there
[Music]
what is that huh
welcome if you
must vomit splatter
spells but splates
splatter please
find something platter
it should not be this hard unclear
unclear
um okay we're looking for clues we're
looking for clues
that is what we are doing
i feel like so
yeah no that checks out
hmm friend stats
world stats oh that's cool okay
yeah but what if we just
checked out
she's crazy i like it
i'm into it tara
the office administrator at basswood
jungle is a proverbial weird co-worker
she likes everyone and everything
dinosaurs
romance novels evangelical tv conspiracy
theories
rice cookies unusual street names
you name it she talk about it for hours
i don't know why i choked on my
knowledge of time
tara has no filter she'd make
a terrible spy or serial killer
hmm or maybe an excellent one
do you think that i'm allergic to making
fun of tara and that's what's happened
to you
okay
[Music]
cool yeah okay
does the jukebox have any clues
somebody's cap that seems like a clue
that we're
overlooking i feel like we should
interact with that maybe it might have
fallen off the table
seems some people got rowdy last night i
mean
yeah i mean yeah we no we figured that
out i think
that's the thing i think we knew mate
[Music]
okay nope
uh uh i feel like i've interacted with
everything have i not
unsure
oh thank you for reading it rob not that
i wrote it obviously
but uh yes omales is a very good story
i feel like we should investigate the
baseball bat as well as all i'm saying
um okay i think i've looked at
everything
let's see if mayhaps there no i cannot
look at them all
in there okay
definitely can't go in here definitely
no okay well
well what else is there to look at it's
possible i've just missed something
can't go in associates only oh that
no can't go in the restroom
see like working poke you anywhere or
something like anything else
to look at i do not know near the table
near the door you say
okay this one
yes
negative whoa who's shooting at me
wow nothing there we already looked at
that
well it's still prompting me to look at
it though do you want me to look at it
twice table
seems some people got rowdy last night
okay soon
jason
no no do you think that i have to win
pac-man
is that what it's gonna do
[Music]
i already looked at that how about these
have we looked at these
i'm not sure what i'm supposed to be
doing
[Music]
hmm we really don't want to look at that
pepper shaker
are you sure about that can i just walk
outside then
no i do not know what i'm missing did i
miss something because i was uh
talking to people too much me hams
ah there it is what knocked this clock
off the pillar
that's gotta be it it seems there was a
fight it could explain the blood on my
shirt
yep does it mean you've caught up
involved probably i won't be able to
find out without more evidence surely
there's a camera in here
there's still more evidence in this room
what in the [ __ ]
okay okay
oh that's okay that's what was not there
before hmm
definitely not the wake nick would have
wished for
yeah she hates beer
what a mess i hope this wasn't me
somebody's business card um she was here
huh
okay cool go go go go go
again anything else for me to look at
now
the fact that still wants me to inspect
the messes
definitely not the wake nick would have
worked it's getting me you know but i
think that maybe there isn't anything
here
i can't aha here's the business card the
right way
wonder why it's here because he was here
fam
that's why in it and maybe now i can go
look at hugh
love you tara miss you hugh where is
hugh
not there he is
who is new in town but it seems like he
knows how to fit in
then again as the town pharmacist
fitting in is part of his job what does
that mean
still it's decent of him to come
to have come to nick's wake
i'm sure uh okay
do you have anything else in here that i
need to locate to be able to deduce
what happened other than
that there may probably have been it
might have fallen off the table
a fight seemed some people got rowdy
like no somebody definitely pushed it
nope that is not what happened
joel's cap there we go so i think it's
in auto is what's happening
maybe we ended up having it out after
all
i think you did boss i think you did
yeah though the clues unlock based on
when you interact with them is what
seems to be happening
which i did not expect
oh yes the pot was completely shattered
looked like it might have been kicked
does it look like it might have been
kicked
i feel like stomped if it were kicked
wouldn't it be
the same blood that was on my shirt it
could be
you think you stabbed a man with a
broken flower pot because that is poetic
flowers are ruined looks like they were
knocked over then
stepped on
dg dennis's initials dennis
was he involved in whatever happened
wouldn't surprise me yeah classic denny
that's what i'm always saying i think
i've seen enough to put together the
pieces of what happened
last night oh that's just gotta think it
through okay
let's go to the mind palace
[Music]
all right there was a fight in it at
least i can always count on this place
to make sense
um do a new york accent i think that i
can only
do boston i don't think i can do new
york because i haven't heard it not what
happened while i was going i did it
hide it i don't know that i can do it i
just i think it's maybe more like joyce
when i try to do new york because it's
too extreme truth is left
i know i got into a fight but it could
have played out in
many different ways that is true it
could have yes i have to think it
through
find out what really happened okay cool
my memory ends here but there's two
glasses
who was here with me dennis
[Music]
i think it was dennis or
whose cap was it was it joel's cap
how to answer the question
tell me how to answer it
i love the way different games approach
these um
detective bits though i am generally a
fan
i would love to who were you drinking
with
i okay that's the only thing i can
interact with right now
is right here so
a great question
we had two people there i mean i know
who you were drinking
on my own somebody approached you
someone approached me i can't remember
who it was but i know we got into a
fight
obviously
i mean we got two people we've we've got
at the scene
and elliot was he the button
if i figure out how the fight went i
should figure out who my assailant was
correct
towards the pillar yes towards the
pillar
something hit the pillar with enough
force to make the clock fall
a person thrown into the pillar would do
it
was i wrong did you tell me i was wrong
no no no no no
this for shot towards the pillar okay
[Music]
uh where did it end was the question
on this stage looks like not even the
memorial board was spared by the brawl
that could be it but i still have to
figure out oh we were at the bar so it
would have had to have gone
that way and then that way is that right
maybe
oh it's not entirely like oberdin but i
do love everything
okay oh that's right i forgot about
hugh's business card that's really hard
to answer
[Music]
is this telling me that i can see what
happens if i break glass
it's possible the fight made its way
over here
i do feel like from there they probably
went there and then went towards the
pillar
i definitely think it ended on the stage
yeah
right i think that makes more sense
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that means that if it ended on the stage
it has to be
whoever had the bracelet right because
they left their breathe that day
i don't think
[Music]
um i'm going to guess dennis that's
dennis's
i definitely wanted to shut him up last
night
right yeah went towards the entrance and
then it went that way
sure
[Music]
and then we went back
[Music]
that can't be right it doesn't match the
damage i understand
i just thought that it would loop i got
what you're telling me
something hit the pillar with enough
force to that's right
yeah the person thrown into the pillar
would do it okay can i validate it now
oh no i have to do the last one again no
no i don't okay
complete picture now gotcha
you know the man who talks to himself
has an
idiot foreign
i see why you have so many friends left
in town yeah
you would know about that be so nice to
ever be a destroyer never slept with my
ex
be so nice who do you blame maura
the backstabbing [ __ ] or the [ __ ]
that's pretty rid of him
hmm you don't talk about anna or nick
that way
do you think you know who nick was mr
perfect
give me a break you have no idea
no one in this town does what does that
mean what are you talking about
i'll show you but not here
hit me later lawrence
ethan is coming back in through the
front at least i
think it's him you think it's him i
can't actually tell
if you can't tell what i know for sure
is if it's ethan he
may not be happy to find you here so i
strongly suggest you leave
i don't have time to lose explaining
myself to ethan get out of here
i guess i can hear how it sounds like
troy it's not troy though like i feel
like it's very obvious to me when
something is troy
um i don't feel like it sounds that much
like him
you funny if i was wrong i know uh
he is working on what did work on what's
it called
[Music]
the medium which i feel like has similar
vibes to this
literally twin mirror uh that's my
blooper team
got delayed actually january 21st now i
think maybe
supposed to come out this month of
course
i come back on the town's miners day
celebration
well you always did have great timing no
time to dwell on that
is it the same voice actor for both of
them
focus you tried dennis's cell phone
no answer so what now ask around
see if anyone's seen dennis today maybe
see if anything jogs my memory
i've heard worse plans dog sweater
no it just says dogs
not watch dogs actual dogs
the superior kind of dog that's what's
small if dennis came through main street
someone saw him
okay let's go let's roll
i did not sort my backwards shirt
situation he said i'm wearing a t-shirt
under the hoodie or the sweater
it's still backwards i've just flipped
the tag on the outside and then flipped
this in so it doesn't scratch me
that's literally been like that all day
and i just didn't notice because i never
took this
sweater off what are my thoughts on the
game so far
seems cool i like this kind of game i
always like a detective mystery
um i get very invested in them so at
least the basswood jungle is still
standing
that's what i was thinking you know at
least at least that
oh that was his it's not worth it
oh showbiz well no one except me
i can't even remember the name of the
first site that i wrote for
luna digital it's called luna digital
it's a web magazine
yeah all that traffic you gotta worry
about
in this this
town full of full of
traffic what are you guys doing you just
hanging out
now i can't just have you hanging around
here all day like a ghost
lots of those countries hey don't give
me that
people have been complaining so don't
let me see you here again you fascist
what you just
i'm just doing my job it's nothing
personal
looks like you're not the only one who
started off on the wrong foot today
thank you sorry you have to see that
some people you just can't reason with
it he just called you a fascist it's not
that bad it could have been a lot worse
you're still in town
um what would he say what would he say
yeah i'm still in town
he's seen dennis yeah checks out you
haven't seen dennis today have you
why are you looking for him i wanted to
apologize
god damn business i'll just stay out of
his way for a day or two oh so we did
get in the first picked up dennis pretty
good last night
cool judging his head's full of smoke
it takes a while to clear so he's alive
here's
it's hard when no one is polite back
people call you pig or fascist just for
doing your job
then they go and do things like to face
the whole town and i'm the [ __ ]
it could get under your skin is
where's he at day after day it grinds
you down
it makes you feel like you've been
lifting logs all day i don't feel like i
prompted this
yeah sorry about that i went off
response you did yes
just remember this town don't always
respect the things you do
trust me i know i don't want to keep you
officer
have a good day keep your nose honestly
i
know that's crazy
all right buddy i'm not sure where i'm
supposed to be going
the perfect toy for a kid who only had
imaginary friends
come on rob you don't want to get in it
[ __ ]
that's my ps5 controller
it's a good point rsg it was a hard
stance on a grocery rocket ride
he just roasted everyone who's ever
enjoyed one of those for no reason
you move i'm the one coming in [ __ ] you
that's enough i keep wanting them all to
kiss
but that's probably more on me than the
game
oh hello i'm in from malaysia kathy and
hugh were both at the wake
i should talk to them you know who this
is though
oh oh sam you know what up
to pick up something for your condition
what i
have a condition yeah the one that makes
you the way you're always so
you oh my god she's so hot it's all
right of course i won't tell anyone
i think i might actually have leaky gut
it's where your intestines starts to
dissolve
and your half digested food starts to
leak out into your blood
still hot i'm trying to find something
for it and
if it doesn't help can't hurt yeah i'm
glad someone took over this old
drugstore can you imagine
you know for sure yeah this town without
a pharmacy would be like well
me with a hole in my gut
i'll just check the internet when i get
home it'll tell me what you get
okay what can i go with you it was
nice talking to you tara very different
responses to talking to her
we could not be more different
what is wrong with you that's not even
correct
also what kind of candy is this no it's
probably chocolate
strategically displayed to make people
spend money on a snack
what do you mean children i am a person
who every time i ever go to a pharmacy
ends up
leaving with m ms or something the
suggestion that it is strategically
placed for children to feel better is
objectively wrong
sam you buffoon the the truth
is that it's for idiots like me who
can't resist chocolate
hi
[Music]
hello
ah samuel sorry about richard he's
always
a little on edge richard i'm surprised
to see you up and about after the night
you
did i kill someone honestly i was afraid
you'd end up like your friend
you were quite inebriated was that a
joke about nick dying
i'm like that honestly i don't remember
everything
you saw me blackout drunk not my finest
hour
i would say not after your bar room
brawl
i did my best to prevent you from
following that other man outside
what other man then i tried to get you
to hand over your keys oh i drunk drove
you
oh i hate me sorry about that
the man i had a fight with
[Music]
[Music]
my writing has done a lot of things to
this town but good
isn't one of them i just think it's a
mess the mind was a band-aid on a torn
artery
sometimes doing what is unpopular is
still the moral choice
doing what
but i find in some cases time is the
best medicine
not in the case of a hangover
suggesting i take nothing yeah i feel
like that's what he'd say he doesn't
want to push pills
that's a new one everything is poison
all that matters is the dose
now you have a good one young man was
there anything else you needed by the
way
just a soul or whatever
i have to ask why move here
of all places you know here
basswood a blink and you miss this town
people move out of basswood that's a
good question
the town i used to work in had a hundred
other pharmacies in it
now you'd make sales but you don't get
it
ever plus
i saw you talking to walter can you ask
him something
i feel like he's all right looks lab
cody um
depends what do you want from him i was
hoping the basswood jungle could run a
piece about me
you see some of the older folks see me
as an outsider still
i can't say i'm sorry journalist
journalism is not
i really appreciate it not how it works
but i'm afraid it's time i get back have
you considered socializing you come see
me again
have you considered involving yourself
in the community
i feel like jumping immediately to
trying to get press coverage isn't the
best idea here
i think maybe they'd see you as more of
an outsider they'd be like why is he got
this
this press release
it's not a good strategy cue
[Music]
alex i assume you're referring to
cyberpunk i'm not sure though
i don't review games so i will not be
reviewing
games ever again
i haven't done it in two years hey kathy
mm-hmm
no sam what can i do you for
it's me trying to be a banjo it's not
right though
it's just i think that's one of those
days i think that's right ran into deck
when i was uh hi scooter my gamer what
playing uh
twin mirrors declan he's testy because
he wants miners day to go well
like in the old days without any trouble
hope you're okay kathy you've been
through some [ __ ]
do you need something
so the wake i am
none of us were on our best behavior
nick would have been happy you showed up
no matter how anything else looks like a
little pinch
i left early myself to go check on joan
she sounds like how i'm trying to sound
in my fantasy about her father being
murdered was real
max payne's voice not what i i just want
her to be
a little girl not a little sam
higgs yikes sneaking around and getting
into trouble
and now all she can talk about is how
you're gonna prove that she's
right sorry i know it's not your fault i
feel like indulging children in there
no curiosity i don't know what to do
to a measured extent is a good idea
she's my daughter
could be really [ __ ] up for a way to
dealing with death they're wrong though
that could
that could be bad i think the sideways
cross necklace is cool we took a [ __ ]
so it's a confusing message is she
religious i would think that
here was much help that is not a
religious way to wear that necklace
because i know like i actually don't
know
i'm just like perfect yawning i'm so
great she's doing an impersonation of my
imagination that checks out
any christmas clothing i do not have
christmas clothing or decorations except
for the thing that
santa monica studio gave me i don't have
enough stuff
i don't have uh uh
enough space is what i mean to say i
have too much stuff
um why would i store anything i consider
getting like a tiny little tree but it's
fine
she's religious in landscape format
half satanist exactly she's literally
halfway between being a satanist and a
christian so i don't know which one it
is
pure fluff journalism
some of the best in the state
cute shoes i like those boots
charity stuffed toy emotional tragedy
turn into a gifts or item
what
what is it that they're selling
the stuffed toys for some kind of
emotional tragedy
to raise money for it
i'm not sure i am not sure what that
means
unclear i'd love to go to the hiking
trailer nil but i don't know where to go
the stuffed animals kill this
grandfather
amazing
you don't understand what the stuffed
animals did to me you weren't there
you'll never understand
j extreme i do actually have a christmas
batman that is one of the other
ornaments that i have hanging with um my
mum bought me a
batman christmas ornament um but
ultimately i just have it on a batman
shelf it doesn't look particularly
christmasy
because you know i don't have a tree it
would if i had it on a tree
i do love going in a music store they
are closed though devastatingly
this feels very open um which is great
have you seen dennis employee
hey don't remember seeing you in town
before
[ __ ] i am this town
i was born in basswood i was raised in
basswood
though i that was you know pretty much
exactly what i thought he would say
even still came back you'd never see me
again if i left
when you leave i don't see that oh okay
yeah sure
i'm just gonna take my millions of
dollars and make a run for it
you could just drive in a car barely get
by like everyone else here
too poor to stay too poor to leave
wow that's very depressing nicole but
you have great hair
and i like your shirt so keep that up
who are you look so far but i should
keep digging around oh
okay you must have seen it that way
gotcha
is there anybody in the diner who's seen
dennis
i don't imagine walter had obituaries in
mind when he became editor-in-chief
it's nick we love nick great friend of
ours hey guys hey what's up
are you guessing dennis celebration used
to be twice as big
no have you guys seen dennis though
excuse me acknowledge me please
i have arrived at your table and i would
like you to pay attention to me
this is extremely rude i cannot believe
that all of you
you're fired
i can't believe i walked next to their
table and they didn't tell me how cute i
am
can you believe that
that's ridiculous that's not for food
now i've gone and made a bit of a mess i
like the characters in this game there's
a lot of variety and i think they're all
endearing could you help an old
daughtering woman you're not that old
christina
[Music]
what would he say do i have a choice
nothing in life is a choice
do i really have a choice dude what's in
front of me or are you just gonna guilt
me with the social contract till i agree
uh well that was a bit gross you i don't
know you had to go that far with it
you always were a character you you got
all in cell with it you didn't have to
do that
okay
thank you so much you're always such a
dude i just roasted you about
social contracts oh sam it's been years
can i have a donut those women out the
front didn't pay attention to me
likewise they didn't even tell me how
much they liked my hood jacket combo
just thinking about it oh dear now i
know you want to interrupt her
because i want to interrupt her because
she decides on me buddy happy thoughts
deep breath he looks very sharp i like
the little red accents on his
speaking of the jonas losing his collar
for the record not saying that that's
behavior that lawrence would exhibit
just keep making fun of him for having
laurence's hair she likes so much to
cheer her up
lawrence is a very nice man he has kathy
now and
well far from me to criticize or
anything but
have you seen dennis since yesterday
have you not learned to not interrupt
people when they're talking sam
i don't have time for small talk wow as
rude as ever
i haven't seen dennis you haven't didn't
you just say that i was lovely before
is this gonna keep track of how everyone
feels about me maybe
i have linda
it would be cool and i again i don't
know if the
notes that you get theater says
christina loves to talk but i don't have
times
i wonder if they update based on the
choices you made like is this changed at
all
no that's the same i do not know
excuse me hey excuse me
hey hello hey have you have you guys
seen dennis
do you like do you like my outfit i put
just the right amount of product into my
hair so that
it looks like i didn't try but it took
me like 45 minutes
excuse me i may have killed a man
it could also be ketchup
[Music]
who are you okay what's up hey man i
thought i knew everyone but i don't know
jonah hill i used to be a regular a few
years ago
oh right you're one of those who skipped
town when the mine closed down
you could say that yes town ain't
changed much since then
same old boring basswood i know most
people hate that but i don't
it's quiet here it's nice
there's no rush hour i guess literally
no trip right
literally the sun from gta it could be
hello sir what are you working on
oh graphs and data tables are efficient
what do you excuse me what are you
working on
sir is it about me is is it about how
cool
my hood to jacket ratio is sir sir
excuse me do you like my shoes so i
think it might be a murderer okay
good day now all right have a good one
all right i'm out
dennis
he's alive though why am i trying to
find dennis so i maybe talk to him about
if i killed someone
not sure
i do like a spreadsheet sam makes cringy
tick tocks
no no i don't think he'd do that i don't
think he's the tick-tock type he
probably doesn't know what it is
but like not in a way that he brags
about not knowing what it is he just
genuinely doesn't know
dennis
dennis jeff
joe sam you old bridge jumper how you
been
what's the calendar say two years joe
it's been two years have you seen dennis
too long did i kill someone or you
showed up yesterday yes may have
murdered someone
unclear too much tequila boys give you
trouble
alcohol i'm doing gonna be alcohol am i
right who knows what could happen
um nothing i couldn't handle maybe a
little nothing i couldn't handle
yeah they might have given helps when
they say wrong voice
it helps it helps the mind closed well
it ain't easy uh bridge jump is a term
for someone who left the town
i've definitely heard that time what
else they've lost their legs recently
dennis you haven't seen dennis today
have you
i wish just about the only guy i could
talk hockey with yeah
not football i want to talk to him grab
actually enjoys a man's sport wow
do you like the sharks san jose or the
ducks
anaheim do you like you like either of
my teams
do you want to talk about hockey what's
your opinion on the shocks
all right well didn't answer my
questions so bye but
it's good to see you just promise you
won't wait two years before saying boo
again
i like him i'll do my best and his cool
er joe has no idea where dennis went
someone must have seen him after surely
somebody instagrammed it you look like a
child
hello is that joan you
seen dennis what are you doing out here
where's it going
waiting for my mom to get off her shift
at the pharmacy drawing
i got a new journal after i left the old
one somewhere it really just looked
six-year-olds
throw pterodactyls in front of abandoned
buildings now
all right did you get home okay last
night yeah
i bike everywhere it's not like anything
scary bad happens in basswood
i heard you asking about my dad i
may be the scary bad
well i guess it wasn't very well was i
no you were not
did you find out anything about my dad
no
not yet not really i'm not even really
looking let me know i'm just trying to
find a man that i think i beat the [ __ ]
out of
i feel like i need something it's just
this town
you know this place
aren't you like three years old you are
much too young to have these feelings
i think i can't stand my mom i don't
like school
it's ridiculous except for science and
just
when i imagine myself in the future i
just
don't i don't think i had any of these
problems as well
nine-year-old people i'm somewhere else
it's gonna give her a different age
every time
i know it's stupid just
cool sweater though what is that like a
unicorn no horn no horn just a pony it's
not stupid
i'd whether you want you can go anywhere
in the world have adventures
fall in love i mean that's what i've
been told anyway
gross okay well that other stuff sounds
okay though
joshua is cool
all right go back to drawing your
pterodactyl in front of the abandoned
building i got grown up stuff i gotta do
nude i've got kid stuff i gotta see
about
so we're both busy look at how metal it
is man i'm a fan i'm a fan
it could be a pegasus i didn't see wings
what didn't i go didn't i just go to the
cafe
[ __ ] i don't think you were there
that's a [ __ ] lie immediately run
into a pole
and then a fire hydrant oops hey guys
i'm back hey
hey did you know that
i may have killed someone
did you guys hear about that no it's not
not made the rounds yet
no okay that's well i'm sure you'll hear
about it tomorrow so
don't worry about it it's going to be
huge news everyone's going to be like oh
[ __ ] sam so cool i heard he killed a guy
maybe you are still not entirely sure
there's blood present yeah that dude's
crazy man anna
oh she doesn't work at the coffee shop
she is working at the coffee shop
betting there will be a few more cups
before she leaves she likes drinking
some things not to change and typing on
her keyboard
it's my favorite thing about her she
never saw me that way
why are any of you here actually show up
i didn't think i would either
but hey sometimes we surprise ourselves
so uh i hear you got enough
oh yeah you heard that yeah you should
see the other guy
what would he say more of a scuffle he
had it coming could barely remember it
i barely remember it's the edgiest thing
to say wasted at that point it's all
just a big
heavy blur yeah after saying i didn't
want to drink
i went home and drank long night
yeah sounds about right
we all deal with stress i don't know if
you heard i killed a guy
he hit dennis you haven't
seen him today have you why afraid your
powerful blows laid him up
thank you for asking why so i don't know
why i was so intent on finding dennis
just to rub his face on how
nature does its best to reclaim the land
after a strip mining operation
that's pretty interesting why she is
keeping your dennis
i can tell something has you spooked
yeah i think i killed a guy i can always
tell
she gets me go on tell her
you could honestly use a non-imaginary
person to confide in
she might slow me down or try to involve
the cops
she might do those things yes or she
might be someone who you can trust
you're awfully close to her
um
he would hide it is the truth that is
what he would do
as much as i would love to tell you
honey i i just want to apologize to him
for what happened yesterday
well he's probably working at the
basswood jungle he's there most weekends
oh did i know that that he's a
journalist did i know that was i aware
of that
i'll check that out i don't remember oh
thank you facts kill opinions
i appreciate your opinion we are not
going to have coffee okay
bye then yeah no that was pretty rude of
me actually
but it's
something about it being alone in the
world no
nobody nobody gets me you know
he is an i.t guy that's right card shop
i forgot about that your boy works in
i.t
uh i passed the bosswood jungle basswood
jungle
i'm not role-playing as him photo i am
role-playing
as a version of him that i have invented
that is not accurate
so all right yeah let's go
locked denise
my my my look what we got
the dude who was rude to me last night
showing your face in town again didn't
you guys get jobs i thought you were
smarter than that
what is this dude's outfit with his cap
and his blazer
i don't want to have this conversation
again my own
we clear i don't it's dumb
um crystal clear
crystal i didn't even walk over to you
you just came over here and then
declan's right down the street he's got
something floating in his face
this is a small town i didn't approach
you
you got you guys brought guy's outfit's
so fancy he sweared a cap
um you guys approached me i don't feel
like any of this was warranted at all
i was just all very rude so
good [ __ ] yourselves is this the back
can i get in here
yeah let's go it's gonna be locked sure
oh well that's terrible security
very concerning wouldn't
wouldn't recommend that uh for you your
building
it's a small town i guess nothing bad
happens until i killed that man
and everything's changing now i gotta go
find dennis
i don't know where to go
been a while this place used to be my
home
i actually can relate to that when i was
a journalist i feel like i lived at ign
i didn't live in san francisco
where is dennis he should be in okay
where is stannis he should be in here
what if i like go through his stuff
dennis
oh my gosh what happened who
did i do this
oh my gosh
is that how i got blood on me did i
oh my gosh
titty palace let's go
yikes bro did i kill this guy
i mean it looks like he got stabbed in
the stomach why are you pushing him
sam
what the hell man
wow
you can do this sam when you focus you
can think through any problem
am i trying to like sam
no oh i didn't mean to do that don't let
it in
focus keep going you got this
dennis i don't want to murder you
i'm just trying to find the man to focus
on are you going to come to me
oh no oh heck
oh gosh oh heck okay there you are
focus
i'm unclear on what i'm focusing on but
i'm doing my dang
best against these horde of denises
who i may have murdered i don't know if
you heard about it was pretty sick yeah
different to everyone else in this town
stabbed in the stomach maybe we're not
sure
more of the chest actually it looks like
it went through his back
and i did that potentially because of
the pills and the alcohol
my wife left me
this is dennis's office there must be
some clues around
oh are you panicking
[Music]
forget if you can solve this
figure this out before dennis dies again
the panic overwhelms you
interesting
i'm actually going to stop here you guys
which i understand is the biggest like
plot twist of all time and i don't want
to stop
is the thing i'm i'm actually quite
interested in what's happening
um and finding this fun
however i feel like
you know we've reached a new point in
the story here and it makes sense for
this to be the point where i stop so i
can
do more work and go to bed such as life
um but i had a good time streaming this
yeah genuinely fun thank you for joining
me
i will put a link in the description if
you would like to check the video game
out and it is in the description rather
put it in the chat here
um yeah this is twin mirror by don't not
entertainment games out on pc ps4
and xbox one this week um genuinely had
a good time with it that was that was
really fun
uh i'm probably not gonna cut this into
a highlight i will leave the full stream
up i think because there's so much
context here this would be a tough video
to cut into a highlight video actually
but
uh yeah thanks for watching everyone
hope you all have a wonderful night
and i will see you all very soon